salut voila la seconde vidéo du format
bleu je rappelle qu'il ya une petite
présentation qui explique comment ces
formats fonctionne la vidéo qui suit est
de niveau
rentrons dans le vif du sujet qu'est ce
qu'un raisonnement
un raisonnement est un type de pensée
est ce qui caractérise cette pensée
c'est son mouvement c'est une pensée qui
opère un trajet bien spécifiques
elle part d'une ou de plusieurs prémices
auxquels elle ajoute d'autres prémices
et cet enchaînement nous fait parvenir à
une conclusion les raisonnements vise à
résoudre des problèmes théoriques et
pratiques
on peut dire qu'il y a plein de formes
de pensée se souvenir fantasmer imaginez
rêvasser évaluer le raisonnement est
différent parce qu'il répond à des
règles dictées par l'objectif donné on a
dit que cet objectif était une
résolution et il y a plein de types de
résolutions différentes par exemple je
veux parier sur un match de boxe mais
impossible de me décider je vais tenter
d'obtenir des informations
je vais évaluer leur pertinence les
comparer d organiser afin d'offrir à
montregard la clarté qui lui manquait
pour choisir sur qui parier
j'avais un problème qui était une
indécision gelé résolu on me prouvant
que j'avais des raisons de parier sur un
tel
toutes ces étapes peuvent être abordés
avec plus ou moins de rigueur et de
précision et cela fera la différence
entre des raisonnements plus ou moins
fiables si vous aimez les énigmes vous
vous retrouvez face à un type de
raisonnement particulier la déduction
aucunement besoin d'aller chercher des
informations et de procéder à des
estimations
toutes les informations nécessaires sont
à disposition et vous devriez être
capable d'en déduire la solution
raisonner ses pensées consciemment en
vue d'obtenir quelque chose une
meilleure compréhension
une motivation pour agir identifié une
erreur et c'est en ce sens raisonnée
c'est enquêter
sherlock holmes miss marple ou hercule
poirot sont célèbres pour leurs
raisonnements face à une situation qui
apparaît inextricable aux lecteurs le
détective arrive à faire le tri dans les
informations distinguer le vrai du faux
pour démasquer le coupable on part d'une
question goût dernier qui a fait le coup
et on a réussi à répondre
miss marple a ce talent particulier de
composition de puzzle des éléments qui
prises séparément ne semblait avoir
aucun sens où intérêt particulier pour
les autres lui permettre de parvenir à
reconstituer l'image c'est à dire à
proposer une interprétation solide
on pourrait dire ceci face à une
situation donnée
on se trouve dans un état de croyance
par état de croyances je vais renvoyer à
l'idée qu'on se fait de la situation
étant donné toutes nos croyances
relatives à la situation
le raisonnement va transformer notre
état de présence soit parce qu'il va
changer notre rapport croyance qu'on a
déjà
soit parce qu'il va produire de
nouvelles croyances cette transformation
peut prendre plein de formes différentes
bien sûr elle peut être radical ou un
film elle peut nous porter vers plus de
certitude ou plus de doute les croyances
ou les hypothèses qui définissent notre
état de croyance
ce sont donc ceux qu'on appelle les
prémices du raisonnement c'est ce qu'on
tient pour vrai ou vraisemblable on
commence par s'appuyer là dessus
le raisonnement suis certaines règles et
appliquer ces règles permet d'obtenir
une conclusion nous ne vivons peut-être
pas d existence de détectives privés
mais cela ne nous empêche pas pour
autant de mener plein de petites
enquêtes par jour si je me demande
combien de temps un trajet en voiture va
me prendre je vais mener une enquête en
allant chercher des informations sur la
distance à parcourir le type de voie
routière disponible le jour et l'heure
du départ la probabilité qu'il y ait des
bouchons etc
si je me demande pourquoi tel collègue
s'est mis en colère soudainement cela va
me pousser à produire une interprétation
psychologique
c'est un raisonnement une forme bancaire
si j'essaie de savoir s'il faut aller
voter ou pour qu'ils devraient voter
je mène une enquête en confrontant des
informations disponibles et mes désirs
et à la vie politique
si je vois une flaque d'eau dans ma
cuisine je vais mener une petite enquête
pour déterminer sa cause si je découvre
que c'est lié à une fuite d'eau sous mon
évier je vais mener une nouvelle enquête
pour déterminer une solution je peux me
demander comment faire pour que ça reste
de fuir les exemples comme vous le voyez
ne manquent pas on peut donc distinguer
le raisonnement théorie qui cherche à
produire une connaissance et le
raisonnement instrumental qui cherche à
résoudre un problème pratique on peut
dire que le dernier exemple de la fac de
illustre sa d'abord une question
théorique
d'où vient cette eau est ensuite une
question pratique comment éviter
l'inondation dans le cas de l'inondation
mais assez vite fixé alors prenons un
autre exemple
mais tant que je me suis donné comme
objectif de gagner beaucoup d'argent
la première question je me pose pourrait
être comment réussir à gagner beaucoup
d'argent
disons que j'identifie de moyens a et b
de gagner beaucoup d'argent
je peux alors me demandez quel moyen
choisir ce qui peut impliquer d'autres
questions plus spécifiques entre a et b
lequel demande le moins d'efforts lequel
sera le plus stimulant
lequel aura le meilleur impact sur la
société à cette dernière question est
intéressante parce qu'elle permet de
révéler quelque chose dans la vie je
n'ai pas qu'un seul objectif
donc il faut enquêter pour vérifier la
compatibilité de mes objectifs
par exemple je veux gagner beaucoup
d'argent et je désire une société moins
inégalitaire
mettons que mon investigation ne
conduise à découvrir que a et b suppose
tous les deux de participer à une
structure économique et social qui
produit des inégalités de richesse je
comprends alors que a et b rendre mes
objectifs incompatibles
mon enquête clarifie les enjeux de ma
prise de décision simon enquête
n'identifie pas de moyens c'est qu'ils
rendraient compatibles les objectifs il
faut que je choisisse quels objectifs je
garde
peut-être qu'on peut identifier un
objectif qui surplombe ses objectifs si
mon objectif ultime est d'être heureux
je peux arriver à la conclusion je
serais incapable d'oublier mes valeurs
ainsi elle m'empêcheront de profiter de
ma fortune donc au final je ne serai pas
heureux
il y a toujours dans les raisonnements
instrumentaux une question cachée du
type
qu'est ce que je suis prêt à sacrifier
pour obtenir x sachant que la réponse
peut être simple je sacrifie cinq
minutes de mon temps pour resserrer un
boulon et réparer cette fuite d'eau ou
très compliqué quand il s'agit de
confronter des rêves des valeurs des
ressources limitées et c'est jusqu'à
présent je n'ai fait que parler des
prémices et de leur lien à la conclusion
émis une
je veux éviter une inondation prémices 2
resserrer le boulon arrêtera la fuite
prémices 3 je suis prêt à faire cet
effort pour éviter une inondation
conclusion je vais effectivement éviter
l'inondation mais j'ai dit plus tôt
qu'il y avait des règles à respecter et
en effet du raisonnement qu'ils soient
théoriques ou instrumentales moral ou
immoral répondent à une norme à une
exigence qui transcende le contexte dans
lequel le raisonnement s'opère cette
norme technologique
si je dis hein je veux éviter une
inondation 2 resserré de boules on
arrêtera la fuite 3 je suis prêt à faire
cet effort pour éviter une inondation la
conclusion je ne vais pas resserrer les
boulons paraît un peu chelou
un raisonnement peut être valide ou
invalide un raisonnement valide et
logiquement nécessaires c'est à dire que
la conclusion est inévitable notez bien
que je n'ai pas dit raisonnement vrai il
faut un raisonnement peut être valide
tout en produisant une conclusion fausse
par exemple parce que une ou plusieurs
prémices sont fausses priez pour que
l'os arrête de poulet suffira à réparer
la fuite
je vais prier pour réparer la fuite
conclusion la prière va éviter
l'innovation le raisonnement le plus
connu dans mon exemple est un avatar
c'est le syllogisme composé d'une
prémisse majeur elle même composée d'un
moyen terme et d'un terme majeur une
prémisse mineurs composé d'un terme
mineurs est un moyen terme et d'une
conclusion qui lient par nécessité le
terme mineurs au terme majeur tous les
hommes sont mortels
composé d'un moyen terme tous les hommes
--des internes majeures mantel spinoza
est un homme
composé d'un terminèrent spinoza et d'un
moyen terme
un homme est l'illusion donc ce qui
n'osa est mortelle ce qu'il faut du
reste puisque chacun sait que spinoza
est éternel évidemment là c'est simple
mais quand on accumule les prémices ça
peut devenir compliqué
et comme on disait un syllogisme valide
n'implique pas la vérité le whisky donne
des super pouvoirs
le camembert est un whisky donc le
camembert donne des super pouvoirs
un syllogisme valide avec des prémices
fausse peut aussi aboutir à une
conclusion vrai mais c'est vraiment du
hasard tous les couteaux à pinson santé
log
tom cruise est un couteau à pain donc
tom cruise est scientologue
c'est syllogisme sont des déductions la
déduction est un raisonnement valide et
logiquement nécessaire là
conclusion s'impose on peut vérifier
qu'une déduction est correct simplement
en regardant sa forme
pas besoin de connaître le contenu des
propositions qui la composent en
l'occurrence le syllogisme fonctionne
par transitivité une propriété la
scientologie est appliquée à un élément
particulier tom cruise en vertu de son
appartenance à un groupe
les couteau à pain auquel cette
propriété s'applique de manière
universelle
cela renvoie au module tendance appelée
aussi détachement ou implication c'est
une règle logique de type 6 à alleur b
en l'occurrence si une propriété à être
scientologues s'applique à tous les
éléments d'un ensemble le couteau à pain
alors tout élément b dont on trouve de
cet ensemble possèdent la propriété à
estreux en posant à on affirme mme b on
retrouve le mot du spawn ans dans les
système de déduction naturel on
l'appelle alors élimination de
l'implication mettons par exemple que
l'on cherche à démontrer une propriété
paix et que l'on dispose d'un théorème
selon lequel si qu à leur paie on va
chercher à démontrer qu une
démonstration en réduction naturelle est
un arbre à preuve par exemple s'il fait
chaud je transpire si je transpire jeu
plus
on peut donc déduire ci a alors c'est
l'été arrive il faut que cette vidéo de
rang évidemment là c'est simplifie à
l'extrême mais beaucoup de raisonnement
théorique implique de faire ce travail
consciemment ou intuitivement le module
tendance est un raisonnement selon
lequel si une proposition est vrai alors
sa proposition contre imposé aussi la
proposition contre imposé 2-6 à alleur b
est sinon b à leurs nanas comme par
exemple si je ne me sens pas mauvais
alors je ne transpire pas et non pas si
je ne transpire pas alors je ne sorte un
mauvais ça c'est une erreur ça s'appelle
la négation de l'antécédent c'est une
erreur parce qu'on n'a jamais dit que la
transpiration était la seule cause de
mauvaises odeurs corporelles
le mot 10,90 génère aussi son quiproquo
ça s'appelle l'affirmation du conséquent
ce serait à partir de si je fait chaud
alors je transpire déduire tu transpires
alors il fait chaud et bien non
peut-être que je transpire pas ce que
j'ai fait du sport
la négation de l'un des ses dents et
l'affirmation du conséquent son départ à
l'autisme formel c'est à dire que ça
renvoie à une erreur logique
au contraire du paralogisme informel qui
concerne la rhétorique c'est à dire
qu'il dépend du langage employé
j'en parlerai dans une autre vidéo on
pourra rétorquer que les raisonnement
déductif ne nous apprennent pas grand
chose parce que les conclusions ne font
qu expliciter ce qui est dans les
prémices c'est vrai mais il est souvent
pertinent d expliciter le contenu des
prémices
sinon on peut aussi faire des
raisonnements par induction par exemple
tous les oiseaux que j'ai observé vol
dont tous les oiseaux volent
ici la prémisse est vrai mais la
conclusion est fausse
c'est simplement que je n'ai jamais vu
de pingouins ou que je ne sais pas
qu'ils appartiennent à la famille des
oiseaux pour autant elle a beau être
fausse cette induction n'est pas sans
intérêt dans la mesure où elle est
statistiquement plus exact que si ayant
grandi sur la banquise
j'avais conclu les oiseaux que j'ai
observés ne veulent pas donc les oiseaux
ne vole pas les deux propositions sont
fausses mais il vaut mieux croire la
première que la seconde le raisonnement
inductif n'est jamais garanti puisqu'il
suppose de faire une hypothèse les faits
pourraient toujours nous donner tort
c'est ce qu'on appelle un raisonnement
ampliatif par opposition aux
raisonnements nécessaire notez que
l'induction n'est pas forcément une
généralisation comme dans l'exemple des
oiseaux ça peut être un syllogisme
statistiques 60% des couteaux européens
sondés scientologue tom cruise est un
couteau à pain
il y à 60% de chances qu'ils soient
scientologues il y à aussi l'induction
simple quand j'ai dit bonjour à pierre
avec un sourire
il m'a répondu avec un sourire quand je
veux dire bonjour à félix en souriant
il me répondra en souriant là je ne me
prononce que sur la prochaine
interactions il existe un autre type de
raisonnement ampliatif l'adduction
il ne s'agit pas d'appliquer une règle
ni de généraliser mais de produire une
hypothèse explicative l'exemple typique
c'est le diagnostic du médecin il voit
tels symptômes et sans avoir besoin de
passer par des analyses sanguines ou
d'autres tests empiriques
il propose une explication c'est telle
ou telle maladie notez qu'il ya plein de
cas où le médecin a besoin des tests
mais parfois il peut s'en passer par la
confiance qu'il a dans son raisonnement
par induction le test peut alors être
utile pour confirmer ou infirmer
l'hypothèse on se demandera si des
observations vont dans le sens de
l'hypothèse
c'est ça la méthode scientifique on
propose des explications et on les
confronte à des observations pour autant
l'adduction fonctionne dans des cas plus
prosaïque
si un ami est étrangement froid avec moi
je pose l'hypothèse suivante j'ai fait
quelque chose qui l'a vexé voir si mon
intuition et précise le fait d'avoir 10
x d'alex et je peux ensuite agir en
fonction de cette hypothèse est par
exemple lui dire au fait je regrette
d'avoir dit que c'est une sorte de test
je vais voir sa réaction que l'on
cherche à prendre une décision a testé
une croyance à comprendre quelque chose
on raisonne sans surprise la
démonstration est la version la plus
pure du raisonnement comme on l'a vu
avec la déduction l'enchaînement des
énoncés ne laisse aucune place au hasard
d'autres questions s'imposent avoir
l'esprit comme par exemple quels sont
les propriétés de ces énoncés sur
lesquels on peut s'appuyer
pourquoi peut-on faire confiance aux
raisonnements qui structure la
démonstration
qu'est ce que nous apprend une
démonstration le raisonnement le plus
pur c'est la tautologie une rose et une
rose évidemment 1 - det gates stein on
peut pas en faire grand chose
normalement une démonstration doit
démontrer quelque chose en mathématiques
dans la tradition d'euclide on pose un
des définitions qui indique en quel sens
seront employées les différents modes
triangle en le droit etc
deux des actions qui sont des vérités
supposé évidente par exemple de choses
égales à une même troisièmes sont égales
entre l étroit des postulats qui sont
des vérités moins évidente que les
axiomes mais nécessaire pour démontrer
les énoncés mathématiques
si l'on accepte ces principes on accepte
la démonstration spinoza a adopté cette
méthode dans les tic qu'il pose de
définition des notions comme celle de
cause de soi de substances d'attributs
puis des axiomes comme ceux qui ne peut
se concevoir en autre chose doit se
concevoir par soi et procède ensuite à
la démonstration de propositions comme
une substance ne peut être produite par
une autre substance on comprend que la
fiabilité de la conclusion issue d'une
démonstration dépens un derek utiliser
deux de la manière dont on applique ces
règles et 3 des hypothèses de départ en
théorie si vous choisissez des
hypothèses qui paraissent très solide
que vous appliquer correctement les
règles adéquates
vous devez emporter l'adhésion attention
au fantasme de toute puissance qui
trouvent là une source d'excitation
les gens qui s'intéressent à la
rationalité peuvent tomber dans ce piège
ce qui démontrait apparaît comme une
vérité qu'on souhaite dans le meilleur
des cas exposés aux autres dans le pire
des cas leur imposer le plus dur est
souvent de se mettre d'accord sur les
hypothèses soit parce qu'elle implique
des valeurs comme par exemple on est
d'accord que le but est de maximiser
bonheur non havas au kenya soit parce
qu'elles reposent sur des définitions
complexes ou subtile ce qui rend
difficile la lecture de l'éthique de
spinoza c'est que pour entendre la
démonstration il faut maîtriser les
définitions et les axiomes tout du long
ce qui est assez exigeant je pense comme
probablement tous les amoureux transis
de spinoza que s'ils ont décuplé
l'endurance mentale moyenne des êtres
humains le monde pourrait devenir
spinosi si vous me permettez une
induction
tout ce que je connais qui ont plongé
dans la démonstration de l'éthique en
ressorte quelque peu illuminée alors
l'éthique pourrait changer le monde la
définition est particulièrement
problématique en cela que c'est elle qui
fondent le sens des énoncés et qu'on ne
peut la font d elle même c'est ce qu'on
appelle le cercle herméneutique
prenons l'exemple du mot être dans le
dictionnaire robert être avoir une
réalité
réalité caractéristiques de ce qui est
réel réel qui existe en fait exister
avoir une réalité confère être nous
voilà bien avancés
d'où l'importance de se mettre d'accord
sur la définition des mots qu'on emploie
si on se met d'accord on peut commencer
à réfléchir ensemble
parfois on peut militer pour une
définition on refuse que tel concept
puisse dire ceci ou cela parce qu'on
craint que cela aura des répercussions
théoriques ou pratiques nuisibles
plus on rend explicite les définitions
et les étapes de la démonstration plus
on donne à l'autre la possibilité de
comprendre pourquoi nous défendons telle
ou telle hypothèse est aussi d'ailleurs
la possibilité de voir les faiblesses
dans notre raisonnement qui nous aurait
échappé
c'est un acte altruiste c'est là la
valeur politique du raisonnement logique
les règles et en expliciter la pente et
devient public
ce n'est pas que le raisonnement logique
donne accès à la vérité c'est qu'il
expose la pensée et le point de vue et
c'est donc un bon moyen pour se
comprendre les uns des autres
merci